Okay, so welcome to video number 16. Here
in this video, we're going to lead into
now foundations of long short portfolio
management. So we're starting with
foundations of long short portfolio
management 1A portfolio modeling. So what
we're going to do in this video is we're
going to take stock of some things that
we've learned so far.
And we're going to start introducing you
into the trade idea generation process
into how we actually start drilling down
into industry sectors in the stock market,
and how we start locating stocks as trade
ideas. And what we're also going to do is
start introducing you to the concept of
actually in practice, being able to choose
your own
risk in your portfolio. And all of this
taken together will lead us into the next
two sections of the PTM video series. So
firstly, the section in the PTM video
series that covers all of the foundations
of long short portfolio management with
all the resources and downloads available
with Excel lessons from Christopher Quill.
And then we lead into
into the whole entire trade idea
generation process. So let's get started
first with a reminder of the pro trader
systematic framework. We split it up into
two areas. We have our theory, as in the
work that we do. And then we have our
implementation. So when we actually start
trading with real money. So on the left
hand
one side, when we think of the side, when
we think of the work that we go through to
actually generate a trade idea, we split
it up into fundamentals and timing and
fundamentals are in the vast majority of
what we do 80 to 90%. This splits up into
both quantitative and qualitative work or
processes.
A trade idea is not complete unless we
know when the right timing is to put a
trade on. And also when we have chosen our
trade structure because we understand the
catalysts that are going to move the stock
within our timeframe of 20 to 60 days.
20 to 60 days. When we actually put our
trade idea on, it becomes a position. So
we have chosen our trade structure and the
position goes on. It becomes a real money
position in our trading accounts. Of
course, we have preemptive risk management
parameters that we place onto our trading
accounts before we even have a position.
But
when we have a position, when we have a
position, it's live, it's real. We
obviously have to manage the risk around
that position once it's live. And then
when we take positions off, the positions
are now complete. They're off. We have a
result. It's either a winner or a loser.
So it's either made money or lost money.
The position is now history. And it
becomes hard coded in our track record
with trader metrics.
And statistical significance. And
statistical significance only occurs when
we've done at least 100 trades, possibly
150 trades over a 12 to 18 month period.
Now, of course, at this stage, when we
look at the entire pro trader systematic
framework, we are still working through
all of the quantitative processes.
processes. We generate our fundamental
trade ideas. We generate our fundamental
trade ideas at the stock level. So our
fundamental trade ideas for stocks. So
what have we covered so far? We've covered
macroeconomic top down leading indicators,
which falls under the quantitative
processes. And we've done this to provide
us with a gauge of whether the bias in our
portfolio is going to be a portfolio is
going to be long, short or neutral at any
one moment in time. So our leading
indicator analysis, what else does it tell
us? Well, it also tells us what we should
probably be leaning towards in our
portfolios, in terms of being long and
short at any one moment in time, because
of our read on the business cycle in that
current
environment. From our leading indicators,
we can also find areas of interest that we
can do further work on in terms of growth
trends and some qualitative statements in,
for example, the ISM manufacturing report,
the ISM non-manufacturing report, and the
European sentiment indicator.
We do get a good idea of interest. We do
get a good idea of which equity sectors we
should be leaning towards in terms of
being long and short at any one moment in
time. And then our next stage towards
building a consistently profitable
portfolio is to extend our quantitative
processes to identify what to actually be
long and short, given our aggregate
portfolio
bias. Now remember, when we actually move
forward to begin selecting stocks for
trade ideas,
what we're going to do in the PTM video
series is we're going to assume cash
equity positions.
So we're not going to be assuming in the
PTM video series that we are utilizing
equity options.
We cover options more in depth in the
Options Trading Masterclass, the PTM video
series. However,
you will be shown later in the video
series where equity options actually fit
in to the overall
process of long-short portfolio
management. Now, something I have to point
out as we're moving
forward in the video series here, there is
no rulebook, guys. Retail traders, I've
said it
before, are always looking for a rulebook
or a list of boxes to tick in all
situations that fit all
scenarios. It doesn't exist, guys. So
you've got to remember all the time, there
is no rulebook.
So let's first define what cyclical and
defensive sectors actually are. So
starting with cyclical
sectors, these are sectors in which the
revenue and earnings of stock constituents
within the sector are
highly correlated to the business cycle.
And then we have defensive sectors. So
sectors in which the
revenue and earnings of stock constituents
within the sector are not correlated to
the business cycle,
or they have a very low correlation. So
thinking about the entire previous section
of the PTM video
series, when we looked at leading
indicators in order to generate our
portfolio bias, when we actually
forecast positive GDP growth, and we
expect positive stock market returns, what
do we want to be doing?
Well, we obviously want to be leaning into
or leaning our bias towards being long
cyclicals and short
defensives. When we forecast that there's
going to be negative GDP growth, or a
significant or let's say
fairly significant GDP slowdown, and we're
expecting a low positive stock market
return, or even a negative stock
market return. We want to avoid being long
cyclicals as much as possible, and lean
our bias towards being
long defensives and short cyclicals. But
it's key to remember this, guys, that
there is no rulebook of
exactly how a portfolio should look in all
scenarios. What we should be seeking to
achieve is to have a healthy mix of
both at any one time. So there's just a
kind of best practices maneuvers that we
tend to work our way around when we have
any one
situation in time. There is no hard and
fast rulebook where you literally go from
top to bottom of a list and tick boxes in
all
So there's just a simple scenarios.
There's just a best practices maneuver
that we try to adhere to.
So for example, if we predict that there's
going to be fairly decent GDP growth, but
we're expecting a 0-1 situation.
Remember the 0-1 situation where we have
the stock market going down, but GDP
printing up. What do we want to be doing?
Well, there's no rulebook on exactly what
we should be doing.
What we want to be doing is maneuvering
ourselves and making sure that we stick to
a maneuver of best practice.
We want to lean our bias towards profit
taking and switching into a short to
medium-term defensive mode with our
portfolios and
possibly adding even hedging instruments.
Now, of course, and we've mentioned this
before, we are traders.
We're not hedgers. We would much rather
find good shorts to make money as the
market goes down.
So we would rather not hedge.
But if we have to because we're struggling
to find good shorts, then of course, we
can do that.
It's just key to remember, and this is a
good example,
that in any one moment in time in the
market, we lean towards certain maneuvers
and certain best practices,
but there is no definitive rulebook on
exactly what we should be doing in all
situations.
But there are things that we want to be
avoiding.
So what we always want to avoid as traders
is being what we call the long bag holder
on the way down
and being the idiot that gets squeezed on
short positions during a strong market
rally.
So if we get the market direction, our
market call wrong for one or two quarters
in a row,
and we have a mixture of incorrect bias
and or we are long and short the wrong
stuff.
What's going to happen? Our returns are
going to get killed.
So it stands to reason at any one moment
in time, we can't be dogmatic.
We have to be flexible and we have to be
willing to change up our positions,
to change our bias depending on what is
happening at the moment in time and
maneuver within a dynamic world.
Remember, there are no hard and fast rules
in trading.
There's just best practices and maneuvers
that we try to engage in at any one moment
in time,
given the information in the world.
So there are no rules that say you have to
do this exact certain thing when you see
this happen
or do exactly this thing when something
else happens.
It just doesn't work like that, guys. We
live in an imperfect world.
The best we can do is play the
probabilities and position ourselves for
what we believe at the time
will be the most likely outcome and that
may happen or it may not happen.
Trading is not a science, nor is it an
art.
In fact, it is a scientific art.
And that's because we live in a dynamic
world and we try to stick to best
practices
and we have maneuverability. We stay
flexible.
So think about what would happen in the
case that you had a 10 stock portfolio
made up of six longs and four shorts and
you were long.
Your six long positions were all cyclical
stocks and your short positions were all
defensive stocks
and you forecasted that GDP growth is
going to slide, go lower from your leading
indicator analysis.
Well, in that situation, if you did
nothing and you just sat there, stared at
your screen,
you do nothing, what would happen? Well,
you would be stupid if you did that.
You need to do something. The world has
changed.
The ideas or positions in your portfolio
are now stale and you are going to lose
money.
So you have to do something. You need to
maneuver. You need to do something.
So there is no rule book in that
situation, even in that situation, on
exactly what to do.
There are an endless amount of potential
actions you can take in your trading
account.
However, the best practice for a trader
would be to change up the portfolio and
put on more quality short ideas.
In order to change the dynamic of the
portfolio.
So I want you to always bear this in mind,
always keep it in the back of your mind
that there is no rule book.
There's just a dynamic world. There's best
practices and there's maneuvers that we
can make as traders.
So we have rigorous processes that we go
through in order to generate trade ideas,
which then become positions, but there is
no rule book on exactly how we should
build our portfolio.
And it can change over time. There's just
best practices and maneuvers that we can
take when
we're shifting from one dynamic to
another. So as we move into the next part
of the PTM video series,
the next two parts of the video series
where we're looking at foundations of
portfolio management.
And we're also looking at drilling down
into the stock market and generating
individual stock ideas.
It's important to remember the backdrop
here. We are providing you with best
practices, a best practice guide.
But in any one situation, in any one
moment in time, there's no rule book and
you have to make the decision
and in how to maneuver from one dynamic to
another.
Just because we have rigorous processes in
our trade idea generation process.
That doesn't mean that when we end up with
real positions that we're not flexible.
It doesn't mean that we're dogmatic. The
two are separate to each other.
So please remember this as we're moving
into the next few stages of the PTM video
series.
And what it really comes down to is just
understanding why things are done the way
they are done by professional traders.
Now, learning the quantitative mechanics
of using stock data to locate potential
stock trade ideas.
That's going to happen in the section of
the PTM video series that follows the next
section.
Before learning how to generate individual
long and short stock ideas.
It's imperative for anyone who has never,
ever been exposed to building and managing
a long short portfolio
to understand some of the key steps in
generating trade ideas that are required
to build optimal long short equities
portfolios and why they actually exist,
why these steps exist.
Only when you understand this are you
going to appreciate why certain things are
done the way they are done in the trade
idea generation process itself.
In the process of figuring out what to be
long and short in a portfolio, we have to
follow these steps as a best practice
discipline.
So we are faced with something called the
stock market and we are in the US stock
market where our universe of stocks is
approximately over 2200 stocks.
And as traders, what do we want to be
doing?
Well, we want to be going where the juice
is.
We want outsized returns.
So we go further than looking at simply
the index level.
So the index, for example, like the S&P
500, we drill down into industry sectors
and those industry sectors can be
classified as either cyclical or
defensive.
And then within industry sectors, we have
stocks and stocks can be classified as
either growth stocks, X growth stocks or
value stocks.
And if we think of this in terms of our
performance, as in what performance we are
trying to achieve here, we want to be
going where the juice is and we want to be
getting better than market returns.
So we are absolute return mandate traders.
We want to make sure that we make money on
the way up and we do way better than the
market return, even though we don't
benchmark ourselves against it.
And if the market goes down, we also want
to be making money when the market goes
down on an absolute basis.
And we don't benchmark ourselves to the
market return.
So from a macro viewpoint, we are always
looking to forecast GDP growth.
And for example, if we forecast that GDP
growth is going to be positive and we're
going to get positive stock market
returns, what are we seeking to achieve?
Well, we are building our long short
portfolios and we're going to be leaning
towards stocks that are going to
outperform both the sector that the stocks
are in and the market in a positive GDP
environment.
And if, for example, we predict that we're
going to see GDP contract or there's going
to be a significant slowdown, we're going
to see profit taking in the market, for
example,
and the market goes down, we want to be
short the right stocks.
We want to be short and leaning towards
shorts in our portfolio stocks that are
going to underperform both the sector that
they're in and the market.
So we're making money on the way down as
well.
And in reality, what we're doing here is
we are attempting to optimize returns in
our portfolio.
So being long the right stocks and short
the right stocks actually given any GDP
environment.
So, for example, everything in yellow in
the stocks boxes are stocks that in any
given GDP environment, we are not
optimizing returns.
So, for example, if you look at the yellow
box for stocks under the red circled box
for stocks, you will see two positives and
a negative.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that you've selected a
stock here that, yes, has outperformed the
market.
Yes, it's outperformed the sector that
it's in, but it's underperformed other
stocks in the sector.
It means you didn't optimize, it means you
didn't pick the right stock in the sector
to be long.
If you look at the yellow box near the
bottom for shorting, that's above the red
circle.
You'll see the yellow box stocks, two
negatives and a positive.
So this particular stock has
underperformed the market, it's
underperformed the sector, but it's
outperformed some of the other stocks in
the sector.
It just means you haven't optimized on the
short side.
If you look at the boxes with the word
sector in, what are these?
Well, if you're looking at a long
environment where you choose a particular
sector, so any stocks in the sector,
this is not optimizing because the sector
has not outperformed the market on the way
up.
And on the flip side, in a short or
environment where the market's going down,
if you choose a sector that outperforms
the market, you are not optimizing.
And of course, any stocks within that
sector.
So what are we trying to achieve here?
Well, we're trying to go where the juice
is.
Therefore, we're trying to always optimize
our returns with an absolute return
mandate.
So we want to be long stocks that
outperform the market, outperform the
sector that they're in,
outperform all the other stocks in the
sector.
And on the short side, given any GDP
environment, we want to try and be short
stocks that are going to underperform the
sector that they're in.
They're going to be the stocks that go
down the most in the sector.
And the sector itself underperforms the
market as well.
So for longs, we want to be in sectors
that are leading the market.
We want to be long stocks that are leading
the sector.
For shorts, we want to be short sectors
that are lagging the market.
And we want to be short stocks within the
sector that are going down the most.
Now, does this mean we actually have
positions in sector products?
No, it doesn't.
We use stocks as a proxy for the sector,
which we're going to come on to a bit
later.
Now, how do we actually go about achieving
this in practice?
How do we process in practice when we're
looking at sectors to be long or short or
stocks within
those sectors more accurately to be long
and short?
What processes do we go through?
Well, we always start with the
classification of our sectors.
And what we're going to be using here is
the Global Industry Classification
Standard or GICS.
Now, there are many different industry
classification standards.
Later in the video series, we will be
using another classification system.
But we're going to be using the GICS
sectors, the GICS standard here,
in order to demonstrate the process.
It doesn't actually really matter which
industry classification system you use.
What is important is the process itself.
So we're going to be using the Global
Industry Classification Standard sectors
here to demonstrate that.
So as we're moving through this example
here, try to focus on the actual process
itself, because you can apply the process
to any industry classification standard.
So you can see the link here, msci.com
forward slash GICS, you'll be able to get
this type of analysis via that URL.
And you can see here, we have sectors at
the top.
So we have what we call super sectors at
Within sectors, we have industry groups.
And here on the page, I selected consumer
discretionary for the super sector.
And within consumer discretionary, I
selected consumer durables and apparel.
And then within that industry group, there
are sub industries.
So household durables, leisure products,
textiles, apparel, and luxury goods.
And regardless of the classification
system that you use for sectors, this is
going to be a typical situation that you
see.
The process is that we are drilling down
from the top sector level to industry sub
sector groups.
So when it comes to this classification,
the GICS system, companies are classified
both quantitatively and qualitatively.
Each company is assigned a single GICS
classification at the sub industry level,
according to its principal business
activity.
So you can see here, we have 11 sectors or
super sectors at the top.
As we drill down, we have 24 industry
groups.
Within that, we have 69 industries.
And then within that, 158 sub industries.
And stocks will be categorized by the sub
industry level, according to their
business activity.
So companies like MSCI and S&P Dow Jones,
they use revenues as a key factor in
determining what the firm's principal
business activity is.
So as traders and portfolio managers,
using industry classifications, it's our
best tool for drilling from the top down
and analyzing from the bottom up, which
stocks we should be leaning towards being
long and short.
Now, I mentioned that later in the video
series, we will be using other
classification systems.
We can also use the North American
industry classification system.
That's something we're going to be looking
at later in the video series.
We will be using that as well.
At this stage, we're just using the GIX
system to use this as an example of how
you would go about drilling down from the
top to the bottom.
So from top sectors right down to the
bottom to sub industries to locate stocks
as potential, interesting, longs and
shorts.
And at this stage of the trade idea
generation phase, what we are doing is we
are engaging in a discovery phase.
We are seeking potential, and that's the
key word guys, potential, long and short
ideas, given our biases and using the
classification system to optimize our
process.
So we're trying to work smart.
Now, of course, based on the definitions
categorized in terms of stocks kept being
categorized by their sub industries using
revenues, there will always be overlap
between sub industries and industries.
Given certain stocks, there will be some
errors or misclassifications of stocks.
So just bear that in mind in your
processes.
So for example, a company that has 50% of
their revenues doing a certain business
activity and 50% doing another business
activity may be classified in one sub
industry when in fact they crossover into
another sub industry.
Don't worry about it.
This is in the vast minority of cases, but
you just have to be aware of it.
Now, in terms of process as traders and
PMs,
we do go to the next stage and we start
categorizing certain sectors and
industries, sub industries, etc.
So we have a download in the downloads
area, a spreadsheet called the GIX
breakdown and you'll be able to download
that and follow the video with each step.
So what we have done in the download with
the GIX example, and this is what it looks
like when you download it, we have
categorized our 69 industries as either
cyclical, defensive or both.
So we have 41 of our 69 industries
classified as cyclical industries, so that
comes out at 59% of all industries
defensives.
So industries classified as defensive
industries.
These come out at 22 in total, which makes
up 32% of our total industries.
So 22 out of 69 making 32% and then
classified as both in the minority, we
have six cases that comes in at 9% of the
69 industries.
So regardless of the classification system
that you're using, and remember, we are
using the GIX system here as an example.
Regardless of the classification system
that you're using, this is the next step
you would take.
You would just simply classify them as
cyclical or defensive industries or as
both.
So in future, whatever classification
system you're using, you can refer to
this.
Refer to the download and look for the
definition of the industry, whether it's
cyclical, defensive or categorized as
both.
And you can apply this to your own
classification system, whichever
classification system that you happen to
be using.
Now, looking at this in a little bit more
detail.
Yes, of the 69 industries classified under
GIX, we assigned a cyclical descriptor to
41 of those industries.
And we assigned a defensive descriptor to
22 of those industries.
Six industries were categorized as both
or, more accurately, not determined as
either cyclicals or defensives.
So we must drill down to the next level.
We look at the sub-industry
classifications and the stocks themselves
within the industry to determine
whether a sector or industry can
collectively be classified as either
cyclical or defensive or the stocks
themselves individually.
Now, of course, when we overlap a
descriptor of either cyclical or defensive
to an industry classification that's
provided by
a system like a system like GIX, we're
always going to run into this problem.
What it comes down to is common sense and
attention to detail.
Now, there is an annual review of the GIX
sectors classifications, and it's always
changing.
So you do need to stay on top of that
occasionally and update your spreadsheets.
Even with this straightforward and simple
approach with the descriptors that we've
given,
occasionally you will find something, a
stock, for example, that is more of a
defensive stock
lumped into the same sector with
cyclicals.
But as mentioned, you know, these cases
are in the vast minority.
And the GIX classifications are derived
from an analysis of how a company makes
its money.
And the classification is still
subjective.
The best we can do is have our process to
assign to the vast majority.
And if we bump into these situations, we
just have to look at it at an individual
stock level.
Now, as mentioned later in the PTM video
series, we will be using the NAICS data.
So the North American Industry
Classification System.
You can use the same descriptors that
we've used here for the global industry
classification standard,
the GIX system, you can use that as the
template.
So use the same descriptors that we have
for the GIX analysis for the NAICS data.
So you can do that and assign the
descriptors yourself.
This will be a good exercise for you to go
through,
just to ensure that you understand the
process and the template itself.
So please do that. Go through that process
yourself.
Now, in terms of understanding why we do
certain things as traders and portfolio
managers,
let's look a little deeper into how we
think about things,
how we approach things when we are seeking
to build long, short portfolios.
So as you will have noticed when we went
through that process of assigning
descriptors,
most industries within the United States
are classified as cyclical sectors or
cyclical industries.
And therefore, the constituent stocks
within those industries would be
classified as cyclical stocks.
So this might lead a lot of people to
think that because there's a lot more
cyclical stocks
in the United States stock market than
defensive stocks.
And that because GDP spends longer periods
of time growing versus contracting,
that as traders and portfolio managers, we
are mostly always long cyclicals and short
defensives.
Well, that's just the wrong way to think
about it. At any one moment in time in the
financial markets,
regardless of forward looking GDP growth
prospects, there will, of course, be good
cyclical stocks and bad cyclical stocks.
So just because, for example, if we think
we're in a very positive GDP growth
environment,
we don't just throw money at long
positions, long cyclicals that are
actually bad cyclical stocks.
We don't have long stocks that might not
necessarily go up a lot given the global
GDP growth environment.
We would obviously much rather be long,
high quality cyclical stocks that are
actually going to go up a lot in a
positive GDP growth environment.
And the same logic applies when we're
looking at defensive stocks on the way
down.
We want to be long the quality defensive
stocks.
We don't want to be long bad defensive
stocks, obviously.
And of course, the same logic applies to
shorts as well.
We want to be short the worst stocks that
we can possibly be short.
And of course, we want them to go down by
a lot.
Now, something else you need to consider
at this stage of your educational
development.
Notice that we are using the word stocks
and not companies.
A very well run, good company does not
necessarily mean that it's a good stock or
long trade idea
for the next 20 to 60 days.
So the time horizon that we expose
ourselves to.
And also a badly run, terrible company
does not necessarily mean
that it's a bad stock or a short trade
idea for our time horizon.
So for the next 20 to 60 days as well.
This is a very common mistake amongst
retail traders.
A trade idea is not either looking to be
long a good company or short a bad
company.
That's not what the definition of a trade
idea is.
So please bear this in mind always.
Additionally, and it's worth reminding you
at this stage,
you should know by now that a trade is not
an investment.
So you need to always make sure that you
get your time horizon and volatility
appraisal correct.
So within the 20 to 60 day time horizon,
we are traders, not investors.
So going back to this process of drilling
from the top down.
We use this process as a prism or lens
through which to view the stock market
and utilize it as a best practice to
optimize returns to get efficient returns.
So if we decide to lean towards having a
net long bias in the portfolio and that
we're going to lean towards
being overly long cyclicals in the
portfolio, we have to be long the right
cyclicals.
So good cyclical stocks for that moment in
time.
And at the same time, we can also be short
bad cyclical stocks and or bad defensive
stocks.
And even at the same time, be long some
good defensive stocks.
The point is that there is no hard and
fast rules here, guys.
And there is no rule book on exactly how
your portfolio needs to look at any
particular moment
in time in any particular situation.
At the end of the day, we just want to be
long stocks that go up.
And we want to be making sure that we are
long the right stocks at the right time.
So they're actually going up a lot.
And we want to be short stocks that go
down a lot and have the right portfolio
bias.
Now, assuming that we already have our
portfolio bias in place,
this is best achieved by first identifying
all of the companies with good
fundamentals.
So for our potential longs and all of the
companies with bad fundamentals.
So for potential shorts.
And what we do in our process, and we'll
be looking at this in great detail later
in the video series,
is that we identify the positive and
negative outliers in each sector.
And we run an inventory of potential
ideas.
And then overlaid with more processes,
these potential ideas may end up becoming
actual trade ideas and then actual
positions.
So at this stage, guys, just remember, we
want to be going where the juice is.
We want to be long, the right stocks,
really good stocks that go up at the right
time.
And we want to be short, really bad stocks
at the right time.
So we want really bad stocks that go down
So yes, we use our classification systems,
our stock classification systems.
We drill from the top down, we assign
cyclical defensive or both descriptors to
each industry.
But when we're locating stocks within the
sub industries, we are looking for great
longs and great shorts.
And we want to be going where the juices.
Now, next thing that we're going to be
introducing you to at this stage in the
video series is we're going to be looking
at the definitions of spread and ratio
traits.
And the reason we're doing this and the
reason why we're doing it at this stage in
the PTM video series,
before we move on to foundations of
portfolio management in more detail,
is because at this stage of your
educational development,
it's really important to understand the
concept of outperformance and
underperformance within a portfolio.
And the best way to highlight this, the
best way to teach it so you understand it
and it sticks,
is to understand the concept of spread and
ratio traits.
And not just the concept, but actually how
it works in practice and how everything is
calculated.
So a spread trade is a trade whereby we
take a long position in one stock.
So let's call that stock A and a short
position in another stock.
And we'll call that stock B.
The spread between stock A and stock B can
be calculated in one of two ways.
Firstly, we can use stock price A and then
minus off stock price B.
So first calculation, stock price A minus
stock price B.
Second calculation, stock price A divided
by stock price B.
So one is a minus and one is a division.
Typically in trading vernacular, the minus
equation,
So stock price A minus stock price B, this
would be known as a spread trade.
And the division calculation where we have
stock price A divided by stock price B,
this would be known as a ratio trade.
But in common trading vernacular, we would
call both of these calculations and refer
to them as spread trades.
So yes, if we were being really picky
about our definitions,
we would refer to the minus calculation as
a spread trade and the division
calculation as a ratio trade.
But if you do hear somebody in the market,
even a professional, refer to something
called a spread trade,
It can actually be either and you would
just have to ask them to define whether
they're using the minus or the ratio, the
division calculation.
So what does this actually look like?
Well, it's pretty straightforward.
Here we have an example where we have two
stocks.
We have our stock A, which is C-H-W-Y,
Chewy.
And then we have our stock B, T-S-N, Tyson
Foods.
And we've minused Tyson Foods off the
Chewy stock price.
So Tyson Foods stock price is minused or
taken away off the Chewy stock price.
So our chart shows this calculation.
So Chewy stock price minus Tyson Foods
stock price.
The chart shows this calculation from the
13th of June 2019 to the 8th of March
2021.
So you can see with the spread between the
two that there's been a negative territory
and positive territory across the time
horizon.
And you can see that there's been a low of
67.85 and a high of 53.13.
And the last price was $10.16.
And when we look at our chart, it's
obviously from left to right gone up,
which means the Chewy stock price has
outperformed over this time horizon the
Tyson Foods stock price.
And when you pull up a stock chart like
this and you've calculated a spread where
it's going up from left to right, this
would be your first thought.
You would just take note that the chart
has gone up from left to right which must
mean that stock A has outperformed stock
B.
Likewise, if we calculate the spread as a
ratio, so we take the Chewy stock price
and we divide that by the Tyson Foods
stock price.
If you see a ratio chart where it goes up
from left to right, it simply means that
the numerator has outperformed the
denominator in the ratio in the fraction
over the time horizon that you're looking
at.
So here on the chart, we're looking at the
same time horizon as before, but instead
of the minus calculation, we're doing a
division calculation to get a ratio.
Over the time horizon, we can see that
there was a low of 0.2459.
There was a high of 1.8104 and the last
price of the ratio is 1.1397.
Now, something worth mentioning here,
whether it's the minus calculation or the
division calculation,
when you are looking at the spread or
ratio traits at any one moment in time,
conventionally, the way you would chart or
the way you would look at the spreads is
you would look at the stock that you're
looking to go long.
And you would use this as in the minus
calculation, for example, as the first
stock and the stock that you're looking to
go short.
You would minus that off the stock that
you're looking to go long.
And in the division calculation, the stock
that you're looking to go long
conventionally would be the numerator.
And the stock that you're looking to go
short would be the denominator.
And in both cases, of course, in the minus
case and in the division case, if we're
using the stock that we're looking to go
long first in the minus case,
and we're taking away, we're minusing the
stock that we're looking to go short.
And in the ratio case, if we're using the
stock that we're looking to go long as the
numerator and the stock that we're looking
to go short as the denominator,
in both cases, we want obviously the chart
from left to right to be going up,
because that means that the stock that
we're looking to go long over the time
horizon has outperformed
the stock that we're looking to go short.
So the charts that we just looked at with
Chewy and Tyson Foods, they showed the
spread,
so the minus calculation and the ratio,
the division calculation of Chewy as a
buy,
a potential buy versus Tyson Foods as a
potential sell or short.
And the point of origin was Chewy's IPO,
their initial public offering in June
2019.
Now, what do these stocks do?
Well, Chewy is an online retailer of pet
food and other pet supplies, and Tyson
Foods is a food distribution company
specializing in meat products supplying
grocery wholesalers and retailers.
So I'll allow you to think about this one.
What descriptors would you actually assign
these companies if you have to?
So would you assign the descriptor of
cyclical or defensive to these stocks?
And within that, would you assign the
characteristics of these companies as
being growth characteristics?
So growth companies, X growth or value?
I'll leave that for you to decide, for you
to do a little bit of homework there.
You might want to refer to the GIX
classification download for some clues.
And also maybe come back to this video
after you've done the quantitative
processing in the trade idea generation
section of the PTM video series,
because you'll get a much better
understanding of what classifies something
as growth, X growth or value.
OK, so for us now, what is really
important to understand,
and this is why we're covering spread
trades, spread and ratio trades at this
stage of the PTM video series.
What is really important to understand now
is the idea of performance.
So outperformance of one stock versus
another or a bunch of stocks long versus a
bunch of stocks short.
Essentially, that's what a portfolio is.
So as mentioned, and as we just covered,
the convention for spreads, when we minus
one stock price from another,
is to minus the stock price of the stock
that we're looking to sell short from the
stock price of the stock that we're
looking to go long.
And for ratio spreads, the convention
there is to calculate the ratio by using
the stock we're looking to go long as the
numerator and the stock we're looking to
go short as the denominator.
Now, when it comes to calculating
performance or outperformance of one stock
versus another.
So outperformance and underperformance of
one stock versus another.
There are complications across the two
calculations.
And Chris Quill is going to go into more
detail about this in the next video.
But essentially, when we are calculating
the outperformance of one stock versus
another using spread calculations,
it's better to use the minus calculation
and we have to assume equal weight.
So when we calculate the percentage
performance, so the outperformer versus
the underperformer for Chewy versus Tyson
Foods,
we look at the Chewy performance first,
Chewy performance over the time period was
the original starting price, which was
$22.
And we minus that off the current stock
price, which was $76.33.
We divide that by the original number, the
original price of $22.
We multiply that through by 100 and we get
a 247% return over the time period for
Chewy.
And for Tyson Foods, the performance over
the same time period, we take the current
stock price, $73.69.
We minus off the original stock price at
the beginning of the time period, $62.76.
We divide through by the original point of
origin price, $62.76.
We multiply through by 100 and we get a
17.4% return in Tyson Foods.
So Chewy as a stock has outperformed Tyson
Foods over the time period by 229.6%.
But of course, in terms of dollar returns,
this assumes an equal weighting to each
stock over the entire time period.
So this is a very understandable and basic
calculation of how to actually go about
calculating outperformance versus
underperformance for one stock versus
another.
So Chris Quill in the next section of the
video series is going to take you through
in the next video in particular,
outperformance versus underperformance in
portfolio modeling.
But at this stage, it's also important to
get your head around the concept of the
amount of risk that you take for the level
of return that you get.
We want to be efficient, long, short
portfolio managers, and we can actually
choose the level of risk we want to take.
So this is how we think about it, and this
is why we're leading into this in terms of
building an overall portfolio by
understanding the different types of
spread and ratio trades that we can expose
ourselves to.
And therefore, the level of risk and
potential return that we expose ourselves
to when building a long, short portfolio.
So there's classically three types of
spread trades in equities markets.
There's cross-sector spread trades.
There's cross-sector constituent spread
trades and intra-sector constituent spread
trades.
So starting with a cross-sector spread
trade, what is that?
Well, that's basically, for example, going
long the S&P 500 consumer discretionary
sector, which is a cyclical sector, and
shorting the S&P 500 consumer staples
sector, which is classified as a defensive
sector.
So you're not actually going long
constituents within the sector themselves.
So stocks within the sectors, what you're
actually doing is going long a sector
versus short another sector.
So this is defined as a cross-sector
spread trade.
Now, what about a cross-sector constituent
spread trade?
Well, that would be going into the sector
itself and picking a stock to go long.
So for example, if we went into the
consumer discretionary sector and we
looked at being long Lululemon, for
example, long Lulu, which is defined as a
cyclical stock.
And then on the other side, for example,
going into the consumer staples sector,
which is our defensive sector, shorting a
stock like Colgate Palmolive.
So CL, short Colgate.
So that is defined as a defensive stock.
But you could also, in a cross-sector
constituent spread rate, be short a
cyclical stock in an unrelated sector to
the sector that you've chosen with the
stock that's in that sector for your long.
So a cross-sector constituent spread rate
is simply being long a stock in one sector
and short a stock in another sector.
Finally, an intra-sector constituent
spread trade is, for example, being long a
stock like Lulu.
So our cyclical consumer discretionary
stock and then short a stock in the same
sector.
So it has all the same characteristics.
It's classified as being in the same
sector.
So in our example here, shorting a stock
like Under Armour, UA.
So our three types of spread trades in the
equities market.
We have our cross-sector spread trade
where we're going long a particular sector
and short a particular sector versus the
long.
And we're not actually taking a position
in stocks themselves.
These would be, for example, going long a
sector ETF versus short a sector ETF.
We have our cross-sector constituent
spread trades where we actually choose a
stock in the sector that we're looking to
be having long exposure.
So we obviously try to buy or go long our
favorite or our best stock that we found
in that particular sector.
And then on the short side, we're shorting
a stock that's a constituent of the sector
that we want to get short exposure in.
So we're looking to be short what we
believe to be the worst stock in that
sector.
But the key here is that the two sectors
long versus short are actually different
sectors to each other.
That's how we define a cross-sector trade.
So a cross-sector constituent spread trade
in this case.
And then we have the intra-sector
constituent spread trade where we're going
long and short constituents in the same
sector.
So stocks make up sectors and sectors make
up the market.
So by default, stocks make up the entire
market.
That's why we call it the stock market.
Of course, we can just be long or short
the index.
So an index like the S&P 500.
However, at any one moment in time,
there's always going to be stocks that
outperform both the market and stocks that
underperform the market.
The S&P 500 index is just the weighted
average performance of 500 stocks.
As traders and portfolio managers, we
obviously want to do better than the
market return.
And of course, this is all set in the
context of absolute return mandate.
As traders, we don't benchmark ourselves
versus market returns.
We want to make money when the market goes
up or down.
Outperformance metrics just aren't
credible if you still lose money when the
market goes down.
Now, understanding these definitions of
spread trades is important for
understanding
the concept of choosing the level of risk
that you take in your long short
portfolio.
So going into the stock market, we have
lots of choices when we're seeking to
build a portfolio
or to have a level of risk that we want to
accept.
Our first choice, of course, is to just be
long or short the market.
So the S&P 500, for example, what's the
risk that we have if we do that?
Well, the market is made up of stocks.
The market is made up of sectors.
Stocks make up sectors.
So we have market risk, we have sector
risk, and we have stock risk.
So stock risk is sometimes referred to as
unique risk.
So risk that is unique to the company, the
stock itself.
And the risk doesn't affect other
companies at all in the stock market.
So, for example, like the CEO of a
particular company dying in a car crash
one afternoon.
That is a unique risk to a company.
It doesn't affect other companies.
Or more realistically, it could be a risk,
for example, that's unique to a particular
company
within a particular sector that's to do
with their supply chain.
So in this particular supply chain, there
might be a risk for a particular company
that no other company has.
And if there's a problem there, it will
affect the company directly and it won't
affect other companies within the same
sector.
So that is what we call unique or stock
risk.
At the sector level, this is a dynamic or
a risk that affects all stocks within a
particular sector.
So it doesn't just affect one stock in a
sector.
It affects all stocks.
So this might be something like, for
example, if a major input cost goes up by
a lot.
So let's say, for example, in the
developer, the housing developer sector,
we have a big increase, for example, in
the price of lumber.
However, this could affect if they can't
pass it on in higher prices of property,
of residential property.
This may cause a big problem in the entire
housing developer sector for residential
housing developers.
So this is the type of risk that affects
not just one stock in a sector, but all
stocks in a sector.
And then we have market risk.
So something typically at the
macroeconomic level that causes a slowdown
or surprise slowdown in GDP growth, for
example, and the stock market goes down
based on that.
Or on the flip side, something occurs in
the world that unexpectedly increases GDP
expectations, growth expectations.
It's higher than the market actually
expects and the market rallies really
hard.
So if we have a position where we are long
or short the index, we have all of these
factors baked into the stock market.
We are exposing ourselves to all of this
risk.
Then we have our cross sector spread
trades.
So where we are, for example, long one
sector and short another sector against
it.
Now, assuming that we are what is termed
as beta hedged, and Chris Quill will go
into this in a bit more detail in the next
section of the PTM video series.
So, assuming that we are efficiently beta
hedged, assuming that we are efficiently
beta hedged, a cross sector spread trade
where we are long one sector versus short
another and beta hedged, we actually
eliminate market risk.
So through beta and correlation, certain
sectors will go up and down either in line
or not in line for every unit or
percentage move in the overall market.
So if we are exposing ourselves to a cross
sector spread trade position and we have
the correct weightings in terms of the
exposure to those sectors, we in theory
eliminate the market risk.
However, we do have sector risk, so risk
that is associated with each sector that
we have a position in, so every stock in
that sector.
And then because we have exposure to all
the stocks within those sectors, we do
actually have stock risk or unique risk as
well.
So, for example, if a particular stock
announces a major profit warning and the
stock goes down 50%, 60%, 70%, 80%, well,
that stock is part of a particular sector
that we have a position in.
So of course, the sector overall is going
to move as well, and that's because each
stock in a particular sector, their
performance contributes to the overall
sector performance.
So with a cross sector spread trade, we in
theory eliminate market risk, but we
expose ourselves to sector risk and
individual stock risk.
Now, when we look at cross sector
constituent spread trades, so when we're
taking positions in stocks that are
constituents within two different sectors,
what risk do we actually have here?
Well, if we're through beta and
correlation, perfect in our weightings, in
theory, we should be eliminating market
risk.
So we have no market risk, but we again do
have in the cross sector constituent
spread trades, like the cross sector
spread trades, we do have sector risk and
we do have stock risk.
So if we go long a particular stock, let's
call that stock A in sector A, and we go
short a particular stock, let's call that
stock B in sector B.
If we have our, through beta and
correlation, our weightings, perfect, we
eliminate market risk, but we still have
sector risk and stock risk.
Now, when it comes to intra sector
constituent spread trades, so that would
be going long a particular stock in a
particular sector versus short another
stock in the same sector.
Again, through beta and correlation, if we
do get our weightings calculated
correctly, we eliminate, in theory, market
risk, and we eliminate, in this instance,
also sector risk.
So in this situation, with intra sector
constituent spread trades, we isolate
stock risk.
So it's important at this stage for you to
understand this in terms of the
definitions of spread and ratio trades,
the definition of spread trades, and how
we actually go about building long, short
portfolios.
So because we have an absolute return
mandate, as traders and portfolio
managers, we simply have to accept that we
must take more risk than the implied
market risk in order to make the most
money possible.
So we have to understand these
definitions, so we have to understand
these definitions, and we have to
understand our risk when we build long,
short portfolios, but in the context of an
absolute return mandate.
We also have to have conviction in calling
a portfolio bias, so whether that's long,
short, or neutral.
And, of course, we have to seek to be long
and short, the right stocks at the right
times.
However, we are walking a tightrope
constantly.
We want risk, and we like risk.
However, we can't simply just take massive
risk and expect massive returns.
We've got to do this with the deployment
of sensible, preemptive risk management
parameters.
And, of course, we're going to be covering
a lot of this further on in the PTM video
series.
So for now, just understand that we are
long, short portfolio managers with an
absolute return mandate.
We want risk, we accept risk, but we can't
take too much risk.
So we choose the level of risk in our
portfolio that we want to take, and we
choose the levels of risk or what types of
risk that we want to be exposed to.
And we attempt to choose a level of risk
that will give us outsized returns, but
walking a tightrope where we're not taking
massive risk and then exposing ourselves
to potentially massive losses or even
massive returns.
So we are always walking this tightrope of
choosing a level of risk, which is enough
for us to get outsized returns, but not
too much that we are exposing ourselves to
unnecessary risk.
And then what we try to do for our
absolute return mandate is juice up our
returns.
So we can juice up the risk and therefore
juice up our returns sensibly by building
portfolios that have higher risk than the
market risk, even whilst eliminating
market risk.
So what type of risks do we want to expose
ourselves to?
What is sensible?
Well, we've got to build long-short
portfolios concentrating on the framework
of cross-sector constituent spread trades
and intra-sector constituent spread
trades.
We have to select the right stocks, long
and short, that have a higher implied risk
than the market risk, and we also have to
have a portfolio bias.
So in terms of walking this tightrope,
yes, of course, we want to accept risk.
We like risk.
We want enough risk to give us the
potential for outsized returns, but we
don't want to take unnecessary,
non-sensible risk.
So we have to look at risk.
We have to look at risk.
So we have to be careful as traders to not
fill our portfolios up with too many long
positions that have corresponding short
positions in the same sector.
So intra-sector positioning.
Intra-sector spread trades will eliminate
too much risk.
So if we filled our portfolio up with too
many of them, we're not taking enough
risk.
So intra-sector spread trades alone is not
going to provide us with enough risk to
get returns that we're seeking as traders
within the 20 to 60-day time horizon.
So we need to make sure that we don't have
too many of them.
If we eliminate too much risk in our
portfolio, we may end up taking a level of
risk that is lower than the market risk,
and therefore we're lowering our expected
returns.
And this is not good in a trader's
absolute return mandate.
We've got to have a good amount of
volatile cross-sector spread trades, and
therefore accept some sector risk, and we
have to seek a portfolio bias.
So we accept some market risk.
So yes, we take the position where if we
can eliminate market risk, and it's the
right thing to do at a moment in time, of
course, we have the choice to do that.
But at the right moment in time, we have
to accept some market risk.
If we eliminate market risk and we
eliminate sector risk all the time, what
is happening?
We're taking too little risk in our
portfolios, and we shouldn't expect to get
outsized returns.
If we accept some sector risk and we take
a portfolio bias at the right times, so
accepting some market risk, we can get
outsized returns,
especially if we juice up the risk that
we're taking.
So, before moving into the next part of
the PTM video series, it's very important
to understand these definitions of the
types of spread trades that you're
choosing to expose yourselves to,
and the levels of risk that you're
exposing yourselves to, and therefore your
expected portfolio returns.
And if you recall, I mentioned earlier in
this video that the reason why we're
introducing you now to spread and ratio
trades or spread trades per se,
is so you understand the concept or the
reality even of outperformance and
underperformance of one stock versus
another and also a whole bunch of stocks
that you're potentially going long versus
a whole bunch of stocks that you're
potentially going short.
Understanding the idea of how a spread
trade works.
Understanding that is an understanding of
a vehicle to understanding how a
long-short portfolio is built.
So, for example, if you build a portfolio
of, say, 10 stocks, so it's a long-short
portfolio of 10 stocks,
and you have five equally weighted longs
versus five equally weighted shorts,
then, by definition, your portfolio is
simply one big giant spread trade.
So, if we have stocks 1 through 10, and 1,
2, 3, 4, and 5, these positions are all
longs,
and then we have stocks 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
If we use our minus calculation and we
take away our shorts from our longs,
so we take away stocks 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, the
sum of those stocks,
we take away that from the sum of the
stocks that we are long, what do we get?
Well, we get a number that represents our
portfolio performance.
We can also use the ratio or division
calculation.
So, if we take our stocks that we're going
long,
and in this instance, that's stocks 1, 2,
3, 4, and 5,
and we divide that number by the stocks
that we're looking to go short.
So, stocks 6 plus 7 plus 8 plus 9 plus 10,
what do we get?
Well, we just get stocks 1 through 5
expressed as a percentage of stocks 6
through 10.
What's important to understand here, and
this is what we're trying to get across to
you here,
is to understand the mechanism of
outperformance versus underperformance,
and by understanding spread trades, when
you understand spread trades,
it's simply a mechanism for you to
understand how outperformance and
underperformance works
in a long-short portfolio.
So, if all your longs go up, and all your
shorts go up, but less than your longs,
of course, you're going to make money.
If all your shorts go down, and all your
longs go down, but not as much as your
shorts,
you, of course, are going to make money.
But the key here is that you have chosen
the level of risk, so portfolio
volatility,
and the level of correlation that you
want.
At any one moment in time, we just want to
be long, awesome stocks that go up,
and short, awful, crappy stocks that go
down.
And we want to be happy, comfortable,
accepting the level of risk and exposure
that we have in the portfolio in order to
get that return.
So, what you shouldn't be doing is, for
example, just looking at a particular long
and a particular stock that you
potentially want to go short,
and then just building a spread trade, and
then saying,
okay, I'm going to stick that spread trade
in my portfolio,
then choosing another one, then another
one, then another one.
The way you've got to look at this is
understand that when we look at spread
trades,
we're looking at them as a vehicle of
understanding as to how outperformance
and underperformance actually works in a
portfolio.
What you should be looking to do is just
being long, awesome stocks that go up,
and short, terrible stocks that go down.
That's what we should be seeking to do all
the time.
And what's going to happen?
By default, our portfolio is just simply
one big spread trade.
And of course, we want to be choosing the
level of risk,
the portfolio volatility, and correlation
that we want to accept,
and we're happy to accept in the
portfolio.
But of course, we are also walking that
tight rope of taking a level of risk that
is sensible
and not exposing ourselves to a level of
risk that is unacceptable.
So we want to be taking this approach.
We want to be always seeking great longs
that go up and terrible shorts that go
down
and end up with the default situation
where when we have a long short portfolio,
we just see it as one giant spread trade.
So that's an ideal world.
In an ideal world, we do want all of our
longs to go up and all of our shorts to go
down.
This is what we must be seeking when we're
generating trade ideas.
However, the world is not perfect or
ideal.
It will occur that shorts will go up with
longs and longs will go down with shorts.
And that happens from time to time and
will obviously happen quite a lot to us
throughout our careers.
We just have to do our best to minimize
that impact.
We don't purposely put on shorts, for
example, expecting them to go up with a
corresponding long.
So we don't put on shorts for the sake of
putting them on and calling them a spread
trade or calling it a hedge.
We need to always be seeking to be long
stocks that go up and short stocks that we
think are going to go down.
If our shorts end up going up or some of
them go up with our longs and we still
make money, that's okay.
Because we've probably eliminated market
risk or a lot of market risk in doing so.
But we don't go into this with the
intention of putting on shorts against
longs where we think the shorts will
probably go up as well.
We want our shorts to go down.
We want our longs to go up.
We are long-short portfolio managers.
That's what we're seeking to do when we're
generating trade ideas.
So we've covered some important concepts
here in terms of approach for risk and
return in building long-short portfolios.
In the next section of the video series,
Chris Quill is going to be covering four
key components on the foundations of
portfolio management.
These are all going to be quite rigorous
spreadsheet classes.
And we're covering this now so you can get
a clearer picture on why we do things as
traders, long-short portfolio managers,
why we do things the way we do things in
our trade idea generation process.
Additionally, it provides a welcome break
from the rigorous processes of top-down
and bottom-up analysis that we're engaging
in throughout a major part of the video
series.
So the areas that Chris Quill is going to
be covering is firstly portfolio modeling,
then secondly, portfolio volatility,
third, portfolio correlation, and lastly,
fourth, portfolio beta.
So like I said, it's quite rigorous, but
Chris is going to start you off with the
basics and build you up slowly into more
complicated procedures.
In the next video, he's going to show you
how to get freely available stock data and
how to actually model a portfolio's
returns
using the spread trade minus methodology
and the spread trade ratio methodology.
Now, just as a side note, please do not
make the rookie dumb retail trader error
of using Chris Quill's example portfolio
as a basis for generating your first trade
ideas after you've completed the PTM video
series.
You need to be generating your own ideas.
Just look at every video that we do as a
template.
They are examples, and we don't expect you
to copy.
The ideas in the examples, okay?
They're not actually trade ideas.
They are simply examples.
So guys, in the next section, foundations
of long short portfolio management with
Chris Quill.
A lot of spreadsheet work to get your head
around, a lot of concepts to get your head
around too.
Enjoy the next section, and I'll see you
back at the desk a bit later in the video
series.
Thanks.